you guys are filming people when they go
to the bathroom
[Music]
now
why you just Dive Right In you know
around age 12 I just started going for
it you know
no oh god oh help help me what what
happened I fell off the
toilet I'm caught between the toilet on
the
wall what do you need not you someone
else get Pam I think Pam's going to want
to come into the men's room get Ryan oh
he needs to lift me
and needs to clean me up a little bit
bring a wet towel Ryan is uh dead no
he's not I just saw him no can can you
just get up yourself I you only grilled
your foot yeah forget it I'll just get
out
myself no
how oh oh
God
J you want to go in the women's
bathroom no thank you though you aren't
curious not really I've seen a bathroom
before yeah but it's every guy's
fantasy I think you mean a girl's locker
room and in the fantasy there's usually
girls in it
yeah I'm going in go
crazy oh oh my
God this is so great
huh we should do this much more often I
think we hang out an appropriate amount
time what are you doing in here this is
the woman's room you're in here I pay
for that
privilege
okay I'm a pretty normal guy I do one
weird thing I like to go in the women's
room for number two I've been caught
several times and I have paid
dearly stay away from Aaron hey I'm your
boss why don't you uh stay away from me
I'm going to stand where I want okay you
don't want to get on my bad side I've
seen some horrible things I own over 200
horror movies okay that's so weird just
go away no you go
[Music]
away I do
know looks good but you you want to
initially one of those where is my
desk that is weird this is not funny
this is totally unprofessional okay well
you're the one who lost the desk I
didn't lose my desk okay calm down where
was the last place you saw okay who
moved my desk I think you should retrace
your steps okay I am going to tell
Michael and this entire office will be
punished
colder
warmer a little
warmer there you go ooh warmer
warmer warmer warmer warmer cold cold
cold back
up
ooh ooh warmer hot red hot hot very
hot Dwight trud hi Dwight um what sort
of discounts are we giving on the 20 PB
white B jim I've given you this
information like 20 times I
know it's by the
re uh yeah it is now 978 so it's a
discount of 7% okay thank you got to get
back to
work wash your hands
Kevin Michael are you okay okay did you
throw up in there no I'm just pooping
you know how I be but it smells like
throw up in here crazy world a lot of
smells ke you I need to talk to you you
can't be in here this is a lady's B Erin
Erin I respect your privacy but I will
follow you in here every time you go if
that's what it takes he Creed not cool
man
I really think you should leave someday
you are going to tell our grandchildren
about how their grandfather won you back
in a women's room can we talk about this
later I have to go okay ju just read the
letter under your windshield wiper okay
it explains everything okay you want G
well
oh adorable right
I walked in on someone in the bathroom
what I just walked in on someone in the
bathroom who I don't know the I don't
know guy we're meeting with I don't know
I don't know what is it sorry what's
what's what's what did I come here just
just just
just what are you doing don't you know
what I'm doing
yeah but you could tell me what what is
that why are you why are we going in the
bathroom I thought this is where you
like your privacy shut
up what is got into you no no no no what
come on let's go back to the party oh
come on wait we missing everything don't
take that stop it stop it J no no no no
means please
don't the wall right here I'm not going
to slam you against anything you're
acting inappropriate Jan I'm acting inap
for good get out of my
way
no no no no no no
no
Michael
Michael I do not want to talk about it
unbelievable that okay what happened
Michael oh wouldn't you like to know
what happened in the bathroom by myself
hervy suffice to say I finished my
business I was just checking to make
sure everything was fine and my cell
phone fell out and on not in but like on
the rim and then it fell in it's no just
let me tell the story okay Jim I knocked
it with my knee and then it fell in and
then I leaned over and looked and my Glu
tooth fell out of my ear and that fell
in GL and then I got flustered and
everything started falling in my wallet
fell in my tip calculator my candy corn
my white strips all fell in to the
toilet and your keys fell in I threw the
keys in out of anger right this cannot
happen again that's what you said last
time I know I did Phyllis this is not
funny this is not
funny well technically it is toilet
humor which you claim to enjoy it is not
toilet humor it is toilet
tragedy hey
hey you know
what this is the best thing that ever
happened to
me I don't doubt
it ladies and gentlemen a while ago you
witnessed a tragedy that befell me in
the bathroom but As the adage goes out
of great
tragedy is the mother of invention so
without further Ado I would like to
present to you something that I believe
will change the way that we all do
business so to speak
behold the mesh toilet guard handy
portable
self-cleaning this little baby goes
where you
go who wants to give it a test spin
Phyllis
Stanley cev who want
to who wants to take it on its maiden
voyage anyone
come
on here's an idea add a handle that
puppy and you got yourself a tennis
record